what is a class like at the University
of Austin The Forbidden classes it's a
class where diverse views actually
people who hold different opinions are
presented about topics we wouldn't or
couldn't or shouldn't even talk about if
you have a sincere question you're
welcome to ask that even if some people
may be offended by that question so the
University of Austin was founded a
little over a year ago this is a very
ambitious Enterprise we're trying to
build something from scratch
but we're well on our way to doing it we
have some of the best faculty members in
the world some of the best advisors in
the world we're well on the way I mean
just think about it in a little over a
year we've secured well over 100 million
dollars that alone is a remarkable
accomplishment you're going up against a
system of accreditation for example in
which there are built-in mechanisms
within that system to make it incredibly
difficult as a deterrent for new
institutions the University of Austin
came into being as a result of the
ideological capture of American
universities and it was a particular
ideology promulgated by people on the
far left it's sometimes it's called woke
ideology sometimes it's called social
justice with an uppercase s uppercase j
number of donors who have donated over a
million dollars or a million dollars or
above
and there are a lot of reasons for this
they're hopeful they're enthusiastic
they're also just sick of it and they
realize that this is not just an issue
what happens in the classroom doesn't
stay in the classroom this is an issue
of global competitiveness this is an
issue of how we're going to face China
because I can guarantee you China is not
straying for the meritocracy you know
they have the gaokao exam with whatever
you think about it that's given every
year it's a meritocratic exam
we are trafficking in absolute Madness
for which propositions for which the
evidence contradicts
our economic competitors are not doing
this I can assure you so for the donors
this is not just a matter of oh let's
give people an alternative to a broken
educational system and help them live
better lives there are larger economic
issues at play as well the University of
Austin is not a conservative or a
right-wing University the solution which
the presidents of the University of
Austin has said repeatedly Bono canulis
the the solution to left-wing or in this
case far left wing ideological capture
of our institutions is not a right-wing
institution it's a truth-seeking
university
thank you
it has a significant portion of land
that it's been given it's managed to
recruit some of the the world's leading
faculty like Kathleen stock and Richard
Dawkins is on the board of advisors Neil
Ferguson now the famous
historian from the UK last year it had
its first forbidden classes of program
in which we took students from all over
the country we offered a range of
courses
that in in debates we had a debate for
example about gender ideology from
Deidre McCluskey who is the famous
economist who's trans and Kathleen stock
who is fighting trans ideology not trans
people there's a big difference so we've
had a we have a range of Faculty we have
a range of debates we've had a range of
uh conversations that simply cannot be
found in the modern University
after the classes people would come up
and engage me constantly I I was I spent
two weeks there last summer but they
wanted to have spirited conversations
about you know I would say one thing
like I personally believe that there are
moral facts and so we've spent hours and
hours in in on the bus in the classrooms
talking about whether or not their moral
facts and what that means and you know I
felt genuinely challenged like genuinely
like wow these are some thoughtful
people the overwhelming majority of the
students who select these programs they
come from Elite universities and they're
at the top of their field and the other
thing that's amazing to me is the sheer
diversity of students that they've had
they've had
Evangelical Christians they've had
Ardent atheists they've had people from
all over the political Spectrum people
who hold different moral beliefs it's
race blind race will not play any factor
it's Merit
and what's here's the other thing that's
interesting about that even though the
the applications were raised blind we
had a mix of everybody classes there
have been forbidden classes program are
held in person they're held in Dallas
Harlan Crow is the and Kathy Crowe uh
generously donated classroom space for
this this summer again we're going to
have the next set of forbidden courses
programs with new faculty and new
students I think that the Tas for this
next year will be drawn from the
students who graduated last year which
is really an interesting thing as well
so they can
um
relive that experience with a new crop
of students
wanted to prepare for the big opening
which is 2024 it's to find the best
faculty members so
there's a lot of stuff to figure out
should we require SATs acts should there
be grades should like read college maybe
those grades are not a b c d but or
alphanumeric or what have you but there
are essays about each student's
performance should there be a
comprehensive exam should faculty have
tenure what kind of administrative
support should we have should there be
even things like gym facilities you know
should there be something more than a
basketball hoop so you're you're talking
about laying the infrastructure the
Scholastic educational and physical
infrastructure for a massive project a
groundbreaking project in which the goal
is to not only rival but surpass the IVs
the first classes will be on ground and
they'll be in 2024 they'll be the first
class of students